this is
a tweet that went viral from
someone who goes by the name professor
nalo
so let's read this it says
my students call me professor nehlo
because i prefer not to use mrs or mr in
my classroom i teach all subjects as a
first grade teacher but my favorite
moments are always when my students ask
about my queerness
she continues i was asked recently
during a podcast interview why i don't
use mrs or mr to refer to myself and i
asked her why i needed to she said don't
you think it'll be hard for children to
adjust
but the truth is it has never been
children that struggle with adjusting to
the complexities of human experience my
students are six to seven years old and
they're steeped in the magic of
curiosity my students know about and
have met my wife at school they know i'm
queer and the turtles will call anybody
out for calling me mrs anything i told
them my story once and never needed to
say it again
if only adults adjust it as quickly and
easily it may save many of our lives
uh and then she continues
from there
this is
another perfect example of of what i've
said before about this the non-binary
phenomenon
um
many different words you can use to
describe it but this is just narcissism
by another name this is a kind of like
sexualized narcissism
and we see that first and foremost
because she's a first grade teacher
calling herself a professor
so that's
leaving aside mr and mrs is a non-binary
she goes by professor
teaching first grade students
which is which is something that like
literally anybody could teach first
graders
and you and if you have first graders
yourself you probably should teach them
yourself
rather than sending them to professor
nalo so they can talk about her
queerness
this is uh this is narcissism this is
you you always find that when they start
talking about why i don't identify with
the labels and you're always going to
hear as we do with the twitter thread
there about the complexity my my
personal
inner experience is so complex i'm such
an interesting fascinating many layered
individual
i mean you the rest of you who just
maybe you're fine settling for mr misses
he or he or she
but that doesn't work for me i i i
the the english language itself cannot
properly describe me in all of my many
complexities because i'm such an
interesting and sophisticated person
that's really the point
somebody totally utterly obsessed with
themselves
and then you add in the sexual dynamic
of this and uh also grooming children at
the same time
talking to your kids about your
queerness
it should go without saying that's
that's not why we send
we don't send
kids to school
to learn about the personal lives of
their teachers at all
and when i went to school i didn't know
anything about any of my teachers i i
knew i didn't i didn't really even know
their first names
it always seemed weird to me that they
had first names
and there was always that weird
experience where you know you have your
like you're out at uh at the grocery
store and you see your
chemistry teacher or something walking
down the aisle in civilian clothes and
it seems so weird and out of place
because this person doesn't belong like
they should just be in a classroom
that's how you think of them
it's not about their personal
experiences you're there to be taught
the academic subjects
um
so
really your students should know almost
nothing about your personal life
but especially they should know nothing
about your sex
and especially when they're first grade
so this is not teaching the word that we
would use for this is uh grooming
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated